et
[Musique]
ça sent bon yann à souk ce soit à
revenus bas l'on doit faire un effort
elle est très bas de cette soupe au même
instant au comptoir d'un café à ça ça
vous voulez des opposants qu'est ce qui
se passe c'est sûrement look est
mauvaise il à faire dans l'analyse et
[Musique]
tenez regardez celle là alain drôle de
goût et ce n'est pas normal que nous
sommes mauvaise ya justement une usine
de filtrage qui la rend potable
[Musique]
à nous voir à la rivière olt mais qu'est
ce qui se passe mais elle est polluée
on le sait lusine d'à côté qui diverses
toutes ces saletés
[Musique]
évidemment le directeur n'a rien voulu
entendre
à tous il faut faire quelque chose
absolument
[Musique]
oh oui effectivement c'est pas beau vous
pouvez avoir entre vite parant au plus
pressé
les petits what our atouts s'occupe de
sauver les poissons
[Musique]
et maintenant à est et où on fabrique
une grille de filtrage et regarder la
rivière redevient propres
[Musique]
ah oui
sanctuaire
[Musique]
bravo à toi tout comme ici
[Applaudissements]
et
le